bueno usted ha sido parte de este
proceso histórico en chile cuéntenos
cómo ha transcurrido este año de trabajo
por una responsabilidad tan grande
verdad
muy buenas tardes santiago un gusto
estar con ustedes y decirles que ya no
soy constituyente soy doblemente y de
nuevo la ciudadana patricia politzer
porque hace unos momentos se disolvió la
convención constitucional y ahora
dependerá el 4 de septiembre que el
pueblo decida si aprueba o rechaza el
trabajo que hicimos durante este año
la diversidad ha sido una de las
características más destacadas por
muchísimas personas sobre el equipo del
cual usted ha hecho parte no la
constituyente como fue trabajar con
voces tan diversas tan diferentes
mira la verdad es que cuando se eligió
la convención se aplaudió mucho esta
diversidad es esta convención multicolor
que nunca había ocurrido en chile que
tuviéramos un organismo con toma de
decisión que tuviera tal diversidad pero
apenas las diversidades empezaron a
pronunciarse a plantear cosas que nunca
habíamos escuchado en nuestro país esta
diversidad ya algunos no les pareció tan
bueno y ahí las cosas se pusieron
ásperas pero afortunadamente logramos
cumplir no sólo con un tiempo muy escaso
no solo con las exigencias que no se nos
pusieron tenía cada norma de esta nueva
constitución
se aprobó tenía que aprobarse con dos
tercios de los votos de la constituyente
y la verdad es que el promedio fue un 75
por ciento
entonces cumplimos en los coros
cumplimos en el tiempo y creo que
también cumplimos con el espíritu que
nos pidió la ciudadanía de una
constitución que vaya a producir
transformaciones profundas en nuestra
sociedad pero que se haga
progresivamente sin que el país se
derrumbe ni tenga nuevas crisis
falta del referéndum como ustedes bien
decía hacía referencia a recién cree
usted que quizás se corre cierto riesgo
de que se transforme quizás más en una
aprobación o rechazo al gobierno de
boris y más que centrarse en la propia
carta magna
bueno el presidente justamente en su
intervención en la ceremonia final hizo
hincapié que este no es un referéndum
sobre el gobierno y yo creo que eso es
muy muy importante
porque la verdad es que el gobierno
tiene que trabajar con miras a las
políticas que debe aplicar en los
próximos cuatro años esta constitución
en cambio tiene que levantar la mirada y
eso es lo que hemos hecho los
constituyentes a los próximos 40 o 50
años ojalá